das maß methan ist verschwunden ein gas
das als hinweis für mögliches
außerirdisches leben in form von
mikroben auf dem mars galt mehrere
missionen hatten das gefunden doch der
eigens zur untersuchung des methans zum
mars geschickte trace mars orbit tgo
findet es nicht mehr
es ist einfach verschwunden wie kann das
sein jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen es wird immer unerklärlicher
methan auf dem mars oder doch nicht als
die ersten vorkommen von methan auf dem
mars gemessen wurden da waren alle
verblüfft was könnte das sein
und dann stellte der mars rover
curiosity auch noch jahreszeitliche
schwankungen fest zitat das
ungewöhnlichste an dieser beobachtung
sind die relativ großen schwankungen wir
versuchen immer noch zu verstehen wie es
zu diesen saisonalen schwankungen kommen
kann so christoph vom jet propulsion
laboratory jpl der nasa gegenüber dem
wissenschaftsmagazin science immer mehr
deutete auf eine biologische erklärung
hin der methangehalt war zwar wahnsinnig
gering stieg aber jahreszeitbedingt um
mehr als das doppelte von dem schnitt
0,3 auf bis zu 0,7 parts per million
also 0,3 bis 0,7 millionste und das im
spätsommer in der nähe des äquators
meteore wurden vermutet aber auch diese
idee musste verworfen werden selbst
massenhafter einschläge ließen den
methangehalt überhaupt nicht ansteigen
mike muller vom goddard space flight
center der nasa die andere erklärung
über die kaum jemand spricht an die aber
fast jeder denkt ist biologische
aktivität auch vom leben erwarten wir
schließlich eine gewisse jahreszeitliche
abhängigkeit und nummer hat etwas
absolut spektakuläres gemessen er und
sein team haben sogar einen anstieg auf
45 pp gemessen während der mars rover
curiosity im mars krater gale anstiege
auf bis zu 7 ppg registrieren konnte
also das zwanzigfache und sogar das
hundertfache wahnsinn was ist da im
boden was das gas produziert fragten
sich die forschungsteams auf der erde
zum beispiel stufen kühlt das gas beim
russen aus oder bakterien die verfaulen
es ist wirklich ziemlich rätselhaft und
wurde jetzt noch rätselhaft
seit april 2018 erkundet der trays gas
orbiter tgo der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa das methan
vorkommen es ist eines der haupt
missionsziele des orbiters spurengase
also trace gas also die geringen mengen
in der marsatmosphäre zu analysieren und
die quelle zu finden aber er findet
einfach nicht nur nachsingen die nada
und dabei funktionieren die instrumente
perfekt und sie messen das methan bis
unten für oberfläche es müsste also
eigentlich da sein und selbst wenn es
keine mikroben oder geologische
aktivitäten gebe sondern es gebe ja auch
das methan das eigentlich durch den
staub aus dem weltraum in der atmosphäre
entstehen müsste eine erste erkenntnis
deshalb zitat von chris website das
methan kommt nicht von oben das ist
schon mal ein wichtiges ergebnis
na toll kein ergebnis ist auch ein
ergebnis jetzt erhoffen sich die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dass die lichtmessung auch eine folge
der jahreszeitlichen schwankungen ist
und das methan doch noch auftauchen
würde es bleibt also spannend und
vielleicht stößt der tgo ja noch auf
eine sensation wenn das passiert dann
erfahrt ihr es hier natürlich als erstes
und als allererste wenn er unseren
whatsapp newsletter abonniert dafür hier
einfach draufklicken und da drunter
geht's weiter mit sensationsfund auf dem
mars ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran